president mr. president mr. president
you were just criticizing the w-h-o for
praising China is transparent but you're
saying many of the same things about
China just a couple of months ago so I
mean how do you square your decisions
well I did it trade deal with China
where China is supposed to be spending
250 billion dollars in our country we're
going to be watching very much to see
now we've got a little bit waylaid by
the virus but look I'd love to have a
good relationship with China but if you
look and we made a phenomenal deal China
has paid because of me China has paid us
tens of billions of dollars over the
course of a very short period of time
billions of it some of that money has
been spent to farmers where they were
targeted by China we cannot let that
happen we can't let that happen
so we ended up signing a very good trade
deal now I want to see if China lives up
to it I know President Xi I think he
will live up to it if he doesn't live up
to it that will be okay too because we
have very very good alternatives whu-oh
but I spoken hundreds of people across
the country in the last few weeks who
say they still can't get tested and that
they aren't social distancing because I
know you question
you ready the governor's the governors
are supposed to do testing it's up to
the governor's go ahead governor's are
doing the testing it's now not up and it
hasn't been up to the federal government
go ahead put this guy here it's nothing
but trouble is a showboat if you keep
talking I'll leave and you can have it
out with the rest of these people if you
keep talking I'm gonna leave and you can
have it out with them just a loudmouth
go ahead if you could
clarify are you basically lifting your
slow the spread before the May 1
deadline and how many governors are
going to be running their individual
states some of them will say no I can't
open now and some of them may last
longer than we even would think others
will say I can you can go I don't want
to mention states but there are numerous
states that are in great shape right now
they're viewing the rest of the country
like we don't even believe this is
happening we have a lot of those states
they're set to open practically now I
mean they would be open now we're gonna
let them open sooner than the date we're
going to pick a date we're gonna get a
date that's good but it's going to be
very very soon sooner than the end of
the month but there are many states out
there that are looking at this and
they're reviewing it and they're saying
we shouldn't be even included in this
you know there's some that want to open
up almost now now if we disagree with it
we're not gonna let them open we're not
gonna let them open if some governor
said you know has a lot of problems a
lot of cases a lot of death and they
want to open early we're not going to
let it happen
so we're there to watch we're there to
help but we're also there to be critics
and on testing very important we've
always wanted the states to do the
testing we're now providing great
testing but the state has to provide the
great testing the state has to provide
the ventilators but they didn't do that
so we ended up going into the ventilator
business essentially and we've made tens
of thousands of ventilators and we
solved the big problem for the states
but we want them to do the testing and
we are there to help I'm respectful of
other countries why wouldn't I be
respectful of China in the meantime
China has paid us nothing in your last
administration nothing in any previous
administration they paid us tens of
billions of dollars because of what
we've done and the trade deal we have
they have to give us 250
billion dollars in purchases let's see
if they do that and they're also paying
this twenty five percent are two hundred
and fifty billion dollars in tariffs so
we're taking and women we take it in
billions of dollars for China from China
they never paid us ten cents that's a
great thing now if they don't produce or
if we find out bad things we're not
going to be happy but right now and and
we're doing that that's what we're doing
look we have an investigation underway
we're paying almost five hundred million
dollars we have an investigation
underway on the World Health
Organization we will find out exactly
what went on and we may be satisfied
that it could be remedied and we may be
said of satisfied that is so bad that it
can't be remedied and if it can't we're
going to go a different route for
praising China for being transparent but
you also praised China for being
transparent I'm talking about China's
transparency if I'm so good to China how
come I was the only person the only
leader of a country that closed our
borders tightly against China and by the
way when I closed our border that was
long ahead of what anybody you can ask
anybody that was in the room 21 people I
was the one person that wanted to do it
Deborah can tell you that better than
anybody I was the one person that wanted
to do it you know why because I don't
believe everything I hear and I closed
and if we didn't close our border early
very early long before the kind of dates
you're talking about we would have had
thousands and probably hundreds of
thousands more death please